we start this morning with a dramatic
new twist in the Colorado murder case
that has caught national attention the
man accused of murdering his wife and
family claims he killed his wife after
she strangled their daughters
prosecutors filed nine felony charges
against Christopher Watts yesterday
those charges include five counts of
first degree murder
Omar Villafranca is outside at the
courthouse in Greeley Colorado with
reaction to the defendants story Omar
good morning good morning according to
an arrest affidavit Christopher Watts
says he was having an affair with a
co-worker and he admits he killed his
wife but says he did not kill his girls
I have two beautiful girls I'm truly
blessed with every day after initially
denying involvement in his family's
disappearance
Christopher Watts allegedly told
investigators his pregnant wife Shannon
killed their two daughters four-year-old
Bella and three-year-old Celeste
[Applause]
according to a newly unsealed arrest
affidavit watts claims that moments
after he told her he wanted a separation
he observed her on a baby monitor
actively strangling their younger
daughter while their older daughter was
sprawled out on her bed and blue
he claims he then went into a rage and
ultimately strangled Shannon to death
this is a horrible loan neighbor Kelly
trippy is furious Watts claimed Shannon
killed their children
what's your response it's so wrong it is
so not true that is the last thing she
would have done if somebody has her just
please bring her back I need to see
everybody just days after watts win on
TV pleading for his family's safe return
he allegedly told investigators where to
find their bodies on a property owned by
the company he worked for my office
filed formal charges against Christopher
Lee Watts in addition to the five murder
charges Watts was also charged with one
count of unlawful termination of a
pregnancy in the first degree and three
counts of tampering with a deceased
human body at any point did you consider
the death penalty way too early to have
that conversation Shannon's father was
emotional Monday as he thanked everyone
for their support and prayers they're
greatly appreciated and keep the prayers
coming it's worth noting that Chris
Watson Ernie
Ric was actually given a request to take
DNA samples from the necks of the two
girls now he is expected in court later
on today right behind me where he will
finally face his charges we reached out
to his public defender that had not
heard backed be honest becomes more
shocking and more heartbreaking by the
day Omar thank you